I have a lot of different interests you
know and and those have been reflected
in independent films and studio films
and you know all different kinds of
genres and that's because I'm you know
that's just what I'm interested in you
know for me yeah the actors that I
really kind of admire in the cruise that
I like or guys who when you go see their
film you're not you're getting shades of
them you know but hopefully you're not
just watching like a certain personality
over and over again and I like the guys
that kind of do comedy and drama and can
you know are just really committed I was
saying that I was in like funny friend
shape before this movie came along and
you know we film this movie like two
years ago so this was I just finished
whiplash but I I you know the movie
hadn't come out and I hadn't really done
anything I'd never done a movie that
required a certain physicality from me
although actually in like the first
divergent movie my guy my character was
supposed to be like a tough guy in the
books they said he was like the best
fighter so I did some training for that
but nothing compares the boxing training
look certain movies are going to require
certain things of you and you know maybe
for like this kind of a certain romantic
comedy you know it's pretty much all in
the pages and there's not a ton of like
you know real prep that you need to do
for it with this particular movie you
know I knew I was gonna have to do an
accident I knew that I was gonna have to
get in a certain shape a certain body
fat a certain weight physically and then
I knew I'd have to jump three weight
classes as Vinnie did so I don't have to
then you know gain some weight and yeah
that was um you know I liked that I I
think for me just knowing that I had to
do all that knowing that I had to do
four hours boxing and then do that you
know meet my accent dialect coach and
then go to the gym and then you know
maybe even do like another session and
do all these things like I enjoyed I
enjoyed having to do all these things to
uh to bring this character to life they
could just add some you know it just
adds adds layers to the guy like I love
you know yeah like I love acting the
film business you know that's its own
thing sometimes but in terms are just
like the core of acting and doing scenes
and connecting with your other actor and
collaborating with the director that's
you know to me that's what's exciting
and but you still need a director to
hire you like you still need someone to
to give you the opportunity to you know
play this part or show something that
you haven't shown before so usually you
know there's going to be a couple people
that need to sometimes you take a chance
on you and that's out of your control
you know I think it's really important
to to have a pretty clear vision for
yourself in terms of the career that
that you want to have I think that
people are going to see you kind of do
something beginning of your career and
want you to keep doing that and very
rarely do you have people telling you
like you know you need to be versatile
or you know try this or go outside your
comfort zone that comes from you just
having a really you know strong idea of
what you want to do and I'll tell people
not to get too discouraged in like the
beginning of your career like you know
early on people talk you know whatever
people that go what are these choices
miles making on stuff it's like you're
not really making choices early on I
mean you kind of are but it's you have
limited kind of resources you don't have
the resume and people are just kind of
like putting you in this thing and
you're just happy to work and so I think
it's important to get on set and then as
you kind of start to get a footing in
the business just to um you know just
you know studios and casting directors
don't always have the biggest
imagination with things so I'll just say
be you know be true to yourself and
commit to the other the career that you
want